d'où vient cette envie folle partagé par
beaucoup de se hisser en haut de
l'everest
parce que tout simplement c'est le plus
haut sommet du globe qui culmine à 8848
m
[Musique]
oh
le pic 15 fut découvert par des espions
cartographe de l'empiré britannique à la
fin du 19e siècle
il prit le nom d'un obscur fonctionnaire
georges everest
mais cette montagne restera deux sagas
matin pour les népalais et le saumon
luma pour les tibétains
l'épopée de l'everest peut alors
commencer comme pour la conquête des
poules
le véritable enjeu c'est d'arriver les
premiers sur le toit du monde
les nouveaux explorateurs sont assez des
alpinistes
c'est chose faite en 1953 un
néo-zélandais un sherpa planteurs piolet
au sommet
ils ont chacun un pied au népal et
l'autre au tibet
[Musique]
il faut alors que toutes les nations qui
se place sur ce podium de glace de
l'altitude depuis près d'un demi-siècle
l'everest en a vu passer de toutes les
couleurs jamais l'histoire ne s'arrête
depuis dix ans le toit du monde est
devenu le théâtre de belles
satisfactions anonymes mais aussi celui
d'une dérive sans précédent pour les
néophytes le mythe de la haute altitude
et fascinant
sur l'everest à tout prix tout est bon
pour vendre financer accomplir son rêve
et réaliser son ambition
mais l'augmentation du nombre
d'alpinistes présent sur la montagne
provoquent une pollution depuis plus de
40 ans à 8000 m les expéditions
abandonne matériaux et déchets conservé
par le froid
[Musique]
pour les sherpas ceux qui ont ouvert la
voie avec les premiers explorateurs
cette déferlante de conquérant depuis 50
ans est une aubaine la reconnaissance
mondiale et l'apport de devises ont
transformé leur vie et développer leur
pays
à ce jour ils sont plus de 800 alpiniste
à avoir réussi l'everest mais 150 pas y
avoir laissé la vie
dans cette course de l'extrême et le
dépassement de soi monter encore plus
haut paraît impossible et pourtant
en 1992 des anglais survol l'everest en
ballon
[Musique]
on
le 15 octobre 1978 à 13h dans
l'atmosphère de la compétition mondiale
nous sommes les premiers français au
sommet à cette date seuls 80 personnes
avaient foulé le toit du monde ici
combat ici camp gbagbo est vrai halal à
aller vite depuis 25 ans après voilà
foutu sera pour aller dans nos appels
sommet combat s'appelle sommet compte
d'un appel sommet comment vas-tu au
sommet comme en battue après 25 ans quel
anniversaire
enfin la france au sommet enfin notre
nicolas est notée à mes côtés eh ben je
suis élu si fabuleux on a une chance
après tout nos souffrances
bon courage pierre bon courage pierre
pour la descente
jean avec kurt je vais bientôt tout soit
abandonnée en référé à wilma
bourdonneront quand il s'agit pas trop
grave
je suis très heureux notre chef
d'expédition c'était pierre mazeaud
c'est lui qui arrive maintenant le
visage plein de crème solaire en 1978 il
avait 49 ans nous étions ensemble au
sommet avec nicolas geiger et pulte là
c'est moi joint fana sieff jallet 25 ans
à l'époque
il a déposé sa bouteille à l'épaule a eu
du mi6
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en 1978 bien maso m'avait acceptée dans
son expédition
cet automne pour fêter le vingtième
anniversaire de notre ascension je
propose à pier de repartir au népal sur
nos traces de refaire le chemin qui mène
de katmandou au pied de l'everest
[Musique]
5 roupies vois pas tous les sites sur
pas mal what do you good
[Musique]
oui
allez
[Musique]
pour ce voyage michel pelé nous
accompagne michel et guides de haute
montagne
spécialiste des voyages dans les régions
himalayennes et il a atteint le sommet
de l'everest en 1992
les expéditions ce qu'on gagne peu les
experts de ne plus être protégés
[Musique]
quarante minutes de vol c'est par
katmandou de lukla
cette ati port perché à flanc de
montagne situé à 2800 mètres d'altitude
dans le pays sherpa au début de la
vallée du khumbu
c'est le point de départ d expédition
qui vont tenter l'everest mais également
des nombreux groupes de randonneurs les
trekkeurs qui partent à l'assaut des
sentiers
chaque jour une centaine de personnes
des parcs à 6
à notre arrivée nos anciens sherpa de
l'everest en gal zen pas sangle tchoumba
sont presque tous là ils paraissent ne
pas d'avoir changé
il nous accueille avec émotion
[Applaudissements]
damas et y en a trop la scénario
on va se faire
c'est notre copain ils font golden en
belles fringues alzen en gueule
il est monté aussi l'a84 abc elle ce
qu'on appelle tomboy dont abbas hilton
boy merdy dont eye toy boys rempli fed
il dit la messe pour nous à lukla je
prends conscience des transformations de
la vallée du khumbu de nombreux loggia
les sortes de petits hôtels avec des
dortoirs et parfois des chambres
particulières ont été construits le
tourisme a complètement dévorer les
bords du sentier la maison hop le rite
du chang et des écharpes cheang alzen
est incontournable hilton boy s'est
construit un lodge également avec sa
femme ils accueillent maintenant les
trekkeurs c'est la communion
oh
j'en ai gros scores main
beaucoup
sur la mauvaise odeur et c'est parti en
gal zen alias hilton boy tient
absolument à accompagner pierre tout au
long de notre périple avec cinq porteurs
il nous faut sept ou huit jours de
marche le long de la rivière doute cosy
que l'on traverse plusieurs fois nous
avons passé dans le village de namche
bazar de la rallier pang bocce ferry che
pour ensuite atteindre notre objectif
le sommet du kala pattar et le combat
il ya 20 ans j'avais eu l'impression de
vivre la grande aventure de l'himalaya
aujourd'hui victime de sa célébrité
le chemin du camp de base de l'everest
est l'un des plus fréquentés
nous croisons ainsi des houles de
trekkeurs des groupes de porter qui
travaillent pour les trekkeurs et des
colonnes de yack qui travaillent pour
les porter tout le monde se précipite
sur cet itinéraire attiré par le mythe
du toit du monde et sans doute les
grands parents de ces enfants ont vu
passer les explorateurs et les premiers
conquérants l'himalaya de 1921 à 1938 15
expédition britannique tente sans succès
l'everest par le versant tibétain 24
hommes hyper de la vie dont laventure
des premiers pionniers le nationalisme
semble dominer la volonté d'aller plus
haut et l'atteindre ses limites
en 1950 les chinois envahissent le tibet
et ferme le pays
au même moment le népal ouvre grand son
royaume ignoré en 1952 les fils découvre
la voix du versant népalais de l'everest
raymond lambert et le sherpa tensing
norgay force le passage de la formidable
cascade de glace l'iphone mais il
s'arrête à l'attitude de 8600 m un an
plus tard le même tensing norgay
accompagne edmund hillary
le 29 mai 1953 11h30
les deux alpinistes deviennent des
hommes les plus hauts du monde il offre
cette victoire à la reine d'angleterre
la veille de son couronnement tels
signes devient un héros national au
népal grâce à lui les chats pas du
khumbu vont représenter peu à peu
l'aristocratie du portage et dans le
futur ils prendront eux mêmes en main
leur destin économique
c'est seulement en 1975 qu'une lourde
expédition organisée par le parti
communiste chinois parvient pour la
première fois au sommet de l'everest par
le versant tibétain
ce même versant où tout est première
expédition anglaise avait échoué
une véritable chaîne humaine guidés par
la pensée de mao tsé toung permet cette
victoire
mon du parti rouge comme le feu notre
eau de pluie de la mer de nuages
une cérémonie d'adhésion au parent qui
se tient dans cet endroit peu commun
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'altitude commence à se faire sentir
nous avons dépassé les 3000 m après deux
jours de marche nous arrivons à namche
bazaar la capitale des sherpas une étape
s'impose après avoir été un lieu des
changes pour les caravanes venues du
tibet namche bazaar a connu une
évolution sans pareil la petite bourgade
blotti sur les gradins d'un cirque de
pâturage est devenu aujourd'hui un souk
pour les expéditions et les randonneurs
qui monte vers l'everest
bah tu vois michel je reconnais plus
rien moi à oui c'est devenu une ville
qui maintenant on l'a déjà les plus
cités ça a changé pas mal des choix
débarras catelli les boules hd les fon
le téléphone bon jeu on va en profiter
pour la donner un petit coup de fil ses
fans lui vaut de des boîtes de nuit
namasté je te dit non je te vois sourire
à tous les enfants ce dont je me demande
des fois comme tu es resté longtemps
hein y'a quand même le crâne du yéti les
malades ou des crampons dit la vie
touche il ya tout là y'a le piolet
monsieur norton non bonne analyse de
masse t ya plus rien à acheter en europe
puisque l'étude polaire il fut largement
19 200 bêtes coûte beaucoup moins cher
et cela depuis temps mais jusqu'à 6000
mètres de cordes sur les braises comme
ça et puis même des fois ce qui arrive
souvent c'est que pendant l'expédition
tu t'aperçois quittant banque n'est
qu'en voyant tant voyagé et pour tenir
les rênes de rechercher sur place
bientôt tous ces passionnés delà des
crampons plus récents on regarde les
bouteilles d'eau qui ont utilisé
maintenant vous aviez passable ont cédé
chez sam ayant porté les gt r b movie de
la regarde c'est la propre univers
avec pierre mazeaud en 1978 comme
presque tous les alpinistes depuis la
première ascension à plus de 8 m j'avais
utilisé le lourd de bouteilles d'oxygène
à la fin des années 70 de nouveaux
enjeux vont se dégager une nouvelle
éthique de l'himalayisme commence à se
développer
c'est ainsi qu'au printemps de la même
année l'italien reinhold messner tente
l'exploit
il veut prouver qu'on peut monter sans
oxygène au sommet de l'everest à près de
9000 m meisner fait le pari d'être seul
avec son corps et ses poumons stressé
[Musique]
m
dans la fameuse zone de la mort l'air
est si rare que toute vie est impossible
un homme arraché de la terre est hissé
au sommet de l'everest perdre
connaissance et mouraient en quelques
minutes
cette année-là meissner le premier
bouleversé l'histoire
accompagné de peter haber il a réussi on
peut aller là-haut 100 utilisent
d'oxygène sans artifice
deux ans plus tard mais ce n'est
renouvelle ce défi en solitaire par le
versant tibétain la conquête de
l'everest semble achevée au contraire
avec cette performance
l'esprit d'équipé s'efface
progressivement derrière la recherche de
l'exploit individuel et sportif dans la
vallée du combo ce sera l'afflux de
nouveaux conquérants
on cherche pas de profiter maintenant de
la situation aujourd'hui pour contrôler
l'affluence touristique
les autorités népalaises ont inclus la
vallée du combo dans le parc national
sagarmatha pour y pénétrer
comme pour les expéditions les
randonneurs doivent payer et présenter
un baby trekking délivré par le
ministère du tourisme
huit heures du matin on sonne la cloche
du rassemblement des élèves sur une
vieille bouteille d'oxygène à un sentier
abrupt les enfants de namche bazar se
rendent tous les jours à l'école de kung
à 45 minutes de marche
il y a plus de 20 ans une école ainsi
qu'un hôpital ont été construits ici
sous l'impulsion des mots ni larry après
son ascension de l'everest
il a voué sa vie au peuple sherpa et à
ce village cet établissement accueille
plus de 150 enfants quelle sera leur
destin voudront t-il pour certains
gravir comme leurs parents les plus
hauts sommets de l'himalaya
ici aussi comme à katmandou le mode de
vie occidental bouscule peu à peu les
traditions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui cet instituteur leur
inculquer les bases géographiques de
leur pays ils peuvent prendre ainsi
conscience que leurs valets représente
un royaume de rêve pour les randonneurs
et les alpinistes du monde entier et
devient l'enjeu de leur avenir
[Musique]
et c'est reparti il faut marcher encore
marcher depuis le départ je suis un peu
soucieux pour pierre car le printemps
dernier il a eu des problèmes de santé
on renvoie le pont on est passé
avant-hier f jeunes chez lui disons
faire après la crue c'est les suisses
qui font ça très bien que dans le cadre
de leur coopération
[Musique]
il faut s'acclimater doucement et tenter
de ne pas trop se fatiguer pour michel
tout va bien c'est un indestructible
tout au long de la marche michel pelé va
croiser ses amis chers pas ceux qu'il a
côtoyés au cours de ces 3 expédition sur
l'everest agents disponibles chez toi
non non
il n'avait pas l'air bien ces trois sets
ça fait plusieurs fois le sommet de
l'everest quatre fois et voilà bien
pièce s lot bien d'en payer la note
tous les autres ont des tee-shirts
floqués notre langue et nos grands axes
bien doré et ses amis en great à 10 fois
au sommet en bas bout cette fois au
sommet cadjee qui vient de faire tomber
le record de vitesse en 20 heures sans
oxygène font partie d'une nouvelle
génération de sherpa ils sont des stars
dans leur pays
pourtant pour les médias occidentaux il
reste dans l'ombre sur l'everest
ce sont eux qui prennent maintenant les
choses en mains du camp de base jusqu'au
col sud a vu une lettre
d'autres cher pas conscients de
l'intérêt économique de cette source de
revenus ont su s'adapter aux besoins
saisonniers du tourisme
ils ont peu à peu contrôlées ce secteur
d'activité en créant de nombreuses
agences de trekking et fournissent un
service complet aux groupes de
randonneurs
le style a vanté par reinhold messner
trouve son apogée en 1986 de suisse en
mal de footing erhard loretan et jean
troillet tentent l'ascension directe du
versant tibétain sans oxygène
s'emportant l'altitude l'ascension
éclair en moins de 48 heures des 3500
mètres de la face nord est un véritable
record il nous raconte en direct leur
victoire sur ce thème reste
je pense pour moi j'ai eu la volonté de
dieu qui est avec moi tu y crois
[Musique]
je serais plutôt parler ce qui se passe
dans ma tête c'est pas la première fois
j'ai eu déjà chez lui six nations au k2
en or ici c'est dingue je reviens parce
que les séracs appuyé en permanence un
outil sans d'une caserne
vingt quatre heures plus tard ils sont
au camp avancé 3000 mètres plus bas
par cette rapidité extraordinaire il
signe un des plus beaux exploits sur
l'everest mais déjà un sommet ne suffit
plus dix années seront nécessaires alors
est temps pour entrer dans la légende
comme eisner il mettra son actif
les 14 sommets de plus de 8000 mètres de
la terre la conquête sportive et la
compétition continue
[Musique]
encore quelques minutes de marche et
nous arrivons au village de banques
boîte chez à 4000 mètres d'altitude
michel est impatient de nous faire
connaître son ami galles zen bongo jo
parce que tu es majeur ce mec tu
demandes à monsieur ne viendra pas au
galen weston galles elle n'ira jamais au
sommet de l'everest et ne deviendra pas
un héros
ce n'est pas son objectif il détient un
drôle de record il ouvrait équipe chaque
année la cascade de glace l'iphone
passage obligé de toutes les expéditions
qui vont tenter l'everest
grâce à son travail il a pu lui aussi se
construire un lodge
alors c'est là qu'on constate alors tu
m'as moi je veux dire à la dame
bonjour alarme est possible douch non
d'ailleurs bien little sixteen cfdr la
cascade de glace du khumbu live folle
c'est énorme chaos de glace et bray de
crevasses et de séracs qui barre l'accès
au sommet par le versant népalais un
véritable labyrinthe mouvant qui se
déplacent d'un mètre par jour ce glacier
protège l'everest de ses assaillants
entre le camp de base à 5300 mètres et
le camp 1 1 6100 mètres
galen doit trouver le meilleur chemin
posez les cours de fixe et installer les
échelles qui servent de pont métallique
[Musique]
ces échelles pèse plus de 20 kg des
sherpas les achètent maintenant eux
mêmes directement en inde elles seront
démontées à la fin du séjour des
expéditions et stockés dans le plus
proche village pour être réutilisés la
prochaine saison
tout cet équipement sert de fil d'ariane
et d'assurance pour la progression
jusqu'à la fin des années 80 les
alpinistes équipés eux mêmes la cascade
de glace il amenait tout ce matériel
avec eux mouais
depuis dix ans gaz elles aménagent live
folle avec un assistant le prix de leur
travail est ensuite divisé entre les
différentes expéditions au cours des
deux mois que durent en général une
tentative sur l'everest
galen entretien les ponts métalliques
rectifie le tracé au gré des
modifications du glacier inlassablement
il rallonge les échelles et déplacé
corneau fixe parfois il fait une prière
et jette quelques grains de riz dans la
neige pour amadouer les dieux
aujourd'hui s'engage zen et ses
collègues
l'ascension de l'everest n'est plus
envisageable
[Applaudissements]
on arrive là maintenant à l'endroit le
plus sacré pour les sherpas par rapport
à la bresse le cimetière sacré ouais
c'est beau comme un droit
partout des short n
maintenant on arrive sur la toute la
ligne et de certaines races à céder
certaines qui sont personnalisées part
je pars pour chaque chaire page et aller
non la regarde
tata lieu de création
en général quand isabelle jusqu'ici 6mn
les semaines les corps jusqu'ici toi oui
ils vont la crémation là et après bon si
tu veux évidemment ya pas grand chose
les disperse les cendres après tu veux
il fond il faut tu vois les short n
allez vous tenir au shenzhen bien carré
bien propre et chaque certaine on va
marcher un peu le long de certaines
chaque certaines correspond à un sherpa
qu'elle est alexis d'antoine accident
mais qu'il restait sur les rails on peut
le dire c'est l'éternité se donne aux
manies pas mes hommes et pour les
qualités omani paiement chez ohman et de
nouveau chez ohman rocher on m'a dit de
me ronger
de plus en plus elle est chère pas
qu'ils font c'est qu'ils font le keeper
montag qui font que les
vous êtes étranger donc arriver arriva à
gagner le sommet parce que les sherpas
sont plus en plus habitués à cette
montagne certains gèrent pas ils ont
deux fois par an en sont à leur dixième
ascension de même deuxième ascension et
c'est vrai que c'est une équipe de
leveret ce qu'on espérait derrière
en 1921 les britanniques pour leur
première expédition avait engagé des
sherpas pour les aider leur formidable
efficacité allait transformer leur vie
mais depuis la première ascension le
prix payé en vies humaines par satellite
du népal 50 hommes représentent plus du
tiers des victimes de l'everest
nous arrivons à fait reach et 4500 m
c'est presque l'attitude du mont blanc
je commence à voir à la tête un peu
lourde et je sens que pierre est un peu
inquiet au dispensaire médical
steve un médecin américain du colorado
nous accueille d'où demandé le
streetball dos les bras alors je voulais
demander si je peux prendre un peu de
dia mox quand je sens que j'ai le
souffle court terme des 12,1
à peine sorti nous voyons l'assistante
de steve en train de traiter grâce à un
caisson de décompression un trekkeur qui
a des faiblesses
grâce à ce petit bijou de caoutchouc il
va s'en tirer
il va passer directement en quelques
instants de l'altitude de 5000 m à celle
de 3000 m
depuis quelques années l'utilisation
d'un caisson gonflables comme celui ci a
sauvé beaucoup de vies humaines sur
l'everest de questions je pense qu'il
faut vraiment l'utiliser même par excès
est quelqu'un qui est un petit peu
malade qui va encore juste un mal de
tête
il faut beaucoup de questions c'est très
bien on utilise comme ça en trekking
avec des gens ont mis une heure pour
avoir un effet quand ils descendent 2000
mètres c'est grâce à la question
métallique utilisant le même principe
qu'en 1989
quatre alpinistes extrêmement rapide
eric escoffier christine janin michel
fauquet et stéphane schaffter imagine
avec des médecins un projet presque
fantaisistes ces techniques ont donné
des idées à ses nouveaux conquérants
dont on parle dans la presse
gravir l'everest d'une seule traite
depuis l'europe en s'acclimatant
artificiellement l'altitude avant de se
mesurer au toit du monde l'équipe est
vrai ce turbo passe une semaine au
niveau de la mer dans un caisson
pressurisé
[Musique]
registre fréquence cardiaque et
saturation il leur faut ensuite arriver
le plus vite possible au pied de
l'everest pour tenter l'ascension pour
sa facilité sa rapidité d'accès le
versant tibétain est choisi ils
parviennent en moins de 7 jours à 8000 m
mais malgré l'utilisation de la
technologie moderne
l'équipe turbo sera chassé par les vents
précoces d'hiver
hilton ben ali on y arrive
déjà
en est à quatre mille cinq cent soixante
et on va à 4 1930
après quelques heures de marche pierre
semble de plus en plus fatigué au cours
de la nuit il a un malaise
nous arrivons à le convaincre de faire
l'essai du caisson est de mettre en
pratique la technique du docteur
américain vient de bière mais c'est sûr
que ça va être vachement du bien déjà
doit être sortir tu serais déjà mis
beaucoup mieux que quand tu es rentrée
et puis si ça sinon refus l'heure si on
fait ressortir dans une heure et si tu
commence à devenir vraiment va bien on
trouvait dedans encore une heure et
ainsi de suite
il faut camper faut pomper
foutu la trouille dataflux l'intrus
compter les nous réveiller parce que si
j'ai déjà eu ça ma première création à
la hauteur du camp 1 et même si hélas
les titres m'ont dit c'était la nuit tu
descends tout de suite
et pis tu sens les glouglous qui monte
c'est très désagréable
hélas cette nuit j'ai eu ça je me suis
dit bon ben je compte passer quoi
comme les centaines de randonneurs qui
viennent ici chaque année nous entamons
l'étape ultime du trekking au bout de
laquelle vous pouvez admirer l'everest
dans toute sa splendeur
voir cette montagne de si près c'est un
peu y monter 5400 mètres plus que 200
mètres et c'est bon les scot bonjour
et regarde les jeunes générations ce qui
leur reste dans le groupe senior
balandrade à aller partout et combien de
fois est remonté à l'empt estime toi
michel alors en tissu qui montre qu'une
fois que je suis monté s'il faut que le
sud l'art est due qu'au dessus de semer
j'aurais fait une fois et je risque pas
d'y retourner et regarde il regarde
regarde jamais dire jamais mais là je
regarde le vent au début de l'art et non
en os ou le sommeil wassa souffrent des
toits gens qui retournent pas si j'avais
la forme moi j'ai dit le symbole je me
dirais franchement ça peut se passer
comme la dernière fois on est montés
d'une traite du score sans trop de
problème nous je regarde quelques mecs
qui passionna qui sont presque plusieurs
mois fierté pas vieux et les derniers
pas sinon c'est quoi qui sont plus
rapprochés comme toi mon pays mes
abonnés pour que le filet je suis comme
toi
j'admire pierre malgré ses 70 ans il
monte d'un pas régulier il faut dire que
sur les bancs de l'assemblée nationale
il avait autant qu'en montagne la
réputation d'un battant 3 0
bon
super j'ai beau du câble voit bien qu'au
dessus de l'autre attention qu'elle ne
tombe pas à vis avant de faire une chute
dramatique sur ce sommet secondaire en
1978 nous étions seuls sur l'everest 25
ans nous séparait de la première
ascension
j'avais été le 81e grimpeur au sommet
dans les 20 années suivantes
plus de 700 autres alpinistes vaincrons
le toit du monde avant d'être
commercialisé
les médias vont peu à peu démystifier
cette montagne qui est attaqué de tous
les côtés
en 1988 occidentaux et sherpa confondues
ils sont plus de 250 personnes au camp
de base
une ère nouvelle des ascensions de
l'everest a commencé celle de la
surpopulation cet automne à sans arborer
la signalétique de son sponsor sur ses
vêtements
l'ascension paraît impossible
cette année là le sommet confronté à une
compétition avec des enjeux sportifs
médiatique encore nationaliste et bien
entendu financiers les réussites seront
nombreuses la première américaine marc
batard 24 heures jean marc boivin qui
décolle du toit du monde et d'autres
encore comme nous en 1978 tous
redescendront auréolé d'une parcelle de
gloire
jean marc est parti on peut dire cevr
donc le 26 septembre son vol paraît bien
bien s'effectuer est environ à à 1500
mètres de hauteur de nous il tourne au
milieu lacombe reste ça a l'air très
très calme au dessus et une bonne
affaire de se passait vraiment très très
très bien il vient juste de faire un
virage en trois formats s'intitule the
west est donc pour lui s'il allait super
bien et là vraiment sûr gip sommet de
l'everest
et ce sont les sherpas qui nous ont
prévenu de son départ terminé à vous
alors que boivin va atterrir au camp de
base l'équipe sagarmatha 88 de serge
koenig piétinent à 8000 m elle a raté la
période de beau temps dont les autres
ont su profiter et cela frôle le
ridicule leur progression sur la
montagne est liée au créneau de
diffusion en direct à la télévision
française
des moyens considérables ont été mises
en oeuvre pour ces retransmissions les
médias s'emparent de l'everest
cela devient de cirque en direct sommes
au pied de l'everest maintenant la
petite antenne qui nous permet de
communiquer diriger tout droit sur
l'everest view à 3800 mètres d'altitude
c'est très chic je vous avait déjà
présenté et voici les fameuses à ce vol
c'est un endroit particulièrement
dangereux
nous en avons longuement parlé la
semaine dernière et vous savez que
beaucoup d'api nist ils y ont laissé
leur vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous étions rentrés en contact tout à
l'heure avec serge chronique
ça va être possible de nouveaux didier
anger zabel oui didier serge koenig et
tout ça mais
[Musique]
discutez avec lui cette année côté
tantôt médication avec serge avoir la
force de déploiement lambay la tsr
[Musique]
voilà roger nous sommes pour le moment
coupée nous n'avons plus le son serge
parlé il ya quelques secondes à peine
acquis garibaldi en expliquant que
l'antenne était arraché que le kke
avaient été coupés alors nous essayons
de rétablir la liaison sont avec serge
nous avons cru comprendre qu'il avait
très très froid
c'est lourd c'est lourd
écoute écoute pour vous tuer ce pauvre
serge koenig parvient au sommet dans le
brouillard et le mauvais temps mais il
ne pourra pas émettre en direct les
images tant convoité l'augmentation
sensible du nombre d'alpinistes présent
sur la montagne engendre de sérieux
problèmes de pollution au col sud à 8000
m les expéditions abandonne mata est les
déchets conservé par le froid morceaux
de plastique de verre toile de tente et
vieilles bouteilles d'oxygène dans
l'avenir des opérations de nettoyage
seront organisées mais à 8000 m le
problème n'est toujours pas réglé
attendent ils ont trouvé car évolué à
l'immatériel un si beau mois qu'ils ont
monté la garde les bouts de corde tout
ça va oui car des broches tous ses
proches mais tu as tout ça c'est des
bout du bout des shales des boues des
chiens des bouts de corde 90 92 ans n'a
été jusqu'à 300 camps de base ou c'est
la folie la folie furieuse
mais en réalité c'est les autorités du
népal qui devrait délivrer un son énorme
d'expédition en disant à l'everest y en
aura une à l'automne est un art à une
fois je suis d'accord avec toi mais en
réalité vous dévaloriser la montagne
vous dévalorisez l'everest
quand je vois que l'on 1978 on a mis
trois semaines pour l'équipe et ce bol
et que maintenant les expéditions qui
arrivent ici tout est en équipe et
mettre deux heures pour atteindre
comment ça fait quand même une
différence il ya beaucoup de gens qui
n'auraient qui ne ceux qui
n'arriveraient pas sur se lever si tout
n'était pas équipé ses sherpas
[Musique]
au début des années 90 la médiatisation
et le nombre accru d'alpinistes enlève à
l'everest cette part d'inconnu qui en
faisait un royaume interdit accessible
aux seuls initiés
cette montagne commence à attirer
d'autres candidats moins expérimentée en
1992 michel pelé dirige avec succès l
expédition commerciale card aventure par
matuidi dont on peut on peut imaginer
emmener des clients sommet de l'everest
ceci dit c'est quand même un peu à paris
mais
des agences spécialisées vont proposer
l'everest
il suffit de payer et d'être motivé ses
clients ont payé 150 mille francs
mais ils n'ont pas la garantie d'obtenir
la montagne et non pas la certitude de
revenir vivants essaye comment mes seins
voilà par dessus mais joue à ferrières
c'est quelque chose qui se met sur l'eau
n'est pas sur les yeux et l'on commencé
vraiment selon régler ça essaoui de tout
avis niçois et puis j'avais déjà fait 1
6000 7000 je voulais faire un hymne il
est bon tant qu'à faire
émile pourquoi pas tenter la plus haute
pas s'asseoir et floue et ça c'est une
aventure fantastique et je me suis lancé
dans cette aventure et puis voilà je
suis là aujourd'hui
ce que je trouve ces classes paul sebo
déjà donc c'est sympa surtout c'est
assez ludique comme comme monter à la
fin avec les peintres et sa musique
en revanche ce qui me ce qui m'étonne
c'est la longueur de la descente par
rapport à la montée à monter ce bien et
puis la descente a l'air assez nombre
[Musique]
c'est incroyable marché a priori
impossible draine une véritable
clientèle l'everest business n'est pas
un mythe une réalité plutôt étrange
étrange parce que les gens ni doué ni
très fort avec de la chance sont arrivés
là haut mais pour quelques réussites
spectaculaire et inattendue combien de
drames se sont joués on est toujours
[Musique]
posé la question si jean permanence
j'attends que fasse moins chaud je me
sens bien mais 5h je sais pas comment ça
va
cette année-là à 7200 mètres d'altitude
nos apprentis himalayiste et leur guide
ont le bon sens de renoncer les gens de
plus en plus rêve et ils ont envie de
tenter et seulement là où est ce qu'ils
oublient peut-être c'est que c'est pas
quand on est là haut c'est pas comme sur
la brochure c'est pas comme sur le film
ou sur les photos c'est pas toujours le
ciel bleu et on n'est pas toujours dans
des conditions physiques comme dans son
fauteuil
de 1991 à 1995 afin de stopper
l'affluence mais aussi de procurer aux
pays plus de devises
le gouvernement du népal augmente le
prix du permis d'accès à l'everest de
2300 $ à 50 mille dollars pour un groupe
de neuf personnes
seuls quatre expéditions à la même
saison sont autorisés au même moment la
chine ne demande que 15000 dollars
le flot des grimpeurs se dirige alors
vers le versant tibétain et des
centaines de sherpa sont privés de
travail leur mécontentement oblige les
autorités népalaises en 1996 à ne plus
limiter le nombre d'expéditions mais le
prix du permis passe à 70 milles dollars
au printemps 1996
malgré le coût prohibitif du permis 30
expéditions se trouve sur les flancs de
l'everest et 10 d'entre elles sont
commerciales
une agence américaine propose même
l'ascension du toit du monde avec 100 %
de réussite en échange de la modique
somme de trois cent cinquante mille
francs par personne
en amérique les clients se bousculent
[Musique]
et puisqu'en deux guides sont en
compétition sur le marché anglo-saxon
le néo zélandais robert trolls et
l'américain scott fisher en cinq ans et
deux hommes ont déjà emmené plus de 40
personnes au sommet cette année sont
inscrits un postier de theater une
journaliste la jet set new yorkaise un
médecin un avocat et d'autres encore
tous pensent pouvoir y arriver
m
scott fisher et robert hall ne
redescendront pas avec plusieurs clients
ces guides vont mourir de trop vouloir
réussir le 10 mai 1996 c'est le drame
ils sont 33 naufrage est pris au piège
par le mauvais temps
tous agglutinés sur l'arête terminal à
plus de 8500 mètres d'altitude après
avoir vaincu le sommet dans la zone de
la mort neuf personnes alpiniste amateur
et grands professionnels sont engloutis
dans la tempête
[Musique]
comment peut-on garantir l'ascension de
l'everest avec 100 % de réussite
et pourquoi payer des milliers de
dollars pour s'effacer du monde sur une
arête battu par le vent l'orgueil n'est
sans doute pas étranger dans ce défi
parce qu'on ne peut aller plus haut plus
loin dans l'effort dans la peur dans le
froid dans la douleur
[Musique]
non
même avant cette catastrophe la sur
fréquentation et la prolifération des
expéditions commerciales sur l'everest
et est devenu un véritable problème à
plus de 8000 m aucun secours n'est
possible même avec le meilleur guide on
ne peut compter que sur ses propres
forces et que sur sa propre faculté de
jugement de la limite à ne pas dépasser
[Musique]
pour pierre mazeaud michel pelé et moi
même
la boucle est bouclée après avoir
atteint le camp de base il nous faudra
quatre jours pour rejoindre lukla au
cours de leur descente hilton boy tiens
nous fait rencontrer en fout bas il a
travaillé pour l'expédition d'hillary
c'était l'un des sherpas qui acheminer
le courrier
[Musique]
magnifique
quel âge il a 80 ans il faisait
katmandou combien de chevaux du jour
n'est pas rose à nîmes a dit hier à ta
maison a limité cansalade mythique
dynamique tant qu'ils n'ont pas d'argent
nous attendons de ces bals du samedi
prochain 12 mois
will à la baisse la veste du v de
l'expédition de 78 la très chère pop ne
pas y arriver mais alors là c'est mon
ami il tombe bail de section semblant de
118 ya 20 ans au col sud et même jusqu'à
lui multaq pour porter les bouteilles
d'oxygène alors j'étais apporté un petit
gâteau de cette époque
voilà c'était le boulot vertu voit les
vrais 78 ça c'est pour toi
voilà c'est un souvenir et et toi voilà
namasté mois et demain que se
passera-t-il sur l'everest
tout paraît avoir été fait les sherpas
sont désormais les véritables seigneurs
de cette montagne même s'il ya une
diminution des expéditions les trekkeurs
viendront encore plus nombreux ainsi la
vallée du khumbu continuera à se
développer
pour les alpinistes il n'y a quasiment
plus d'espoir de retrouver un challenge
réellement novateur sur les pentes du
toit du monde
les meilleurs pourront pousser encore
plus loin les limites de la difficulté
mais la recherche de l'engagement total
a déjà provoqué trop de casse à plus de
8000 m
pour moi de l'everest du reste ce moment
unique 90 minutes de bonheur partagé
avec pierre kurt et nicolas au sommet de
la bosse pas grand beau temps et sans
vent
[Musique]